we are here with Adam lamentovich the
CEO of superbet Poland Adam first of all
welcome to the show tell us a bit about
this growing connection between chess
and the Superbad foundation and super
Bell yeah it's a fourth time uh we are
running this show as a super good
foundation second time in Poland but we
are with grantchester since 2020 so it's
really a repetitive journey and with
every every year it's it's really more
fun and and we are more engaged into it
so a really great experience and and
great to be here and great to host so
many great players in Poland and also in
other countries where uh where the tour
takes place
but but in Poland we are really proud to
host all these stars for the second time
and it's not only repetitive but I have
to say you guys are getting better and
better with each and every
um iteration of this super bad
tournament and I have to say that big
board in the middle of uh Warsaw is just
incredible and the QR code everybody
passes by scans the QR codes and gets
connected to the tournament how did that
idea come about well uh we are growing
business and uh and also you know uh we
are quite good in activating not also
our other sports sponsorships we we
treat our engagement with grantchester
and super better Robin and Blades is one
of our big projects across the year so
uh activating this event the weather is
great it's it's good season in Poland so
people out on the streets so create
creating a a big chassis in central
focal point of the city inviting
YouTubers Young influencers from the
Chess World I mean this is definitely
the at the heart of this event because
uh this event is not only about of
course promoting grandchild store super
foundation and our brand but it's mainly
about promoting chess uh as a game and
as connection with uniting people and
and exercising and improving our our
thoughts in mind so I think it's uh it
was natural move and as you said I mean
uh we are getting better into it as as
we saw what what has worked well uh last
year and and we simply try to to improve
on top of that and how did you see that
impact the numbers because yesterday we
had that big chess game between the
influencers the YouTubers as you were
mentioning how did you see that impact
the numbers of young players joining
jazz
I mean uh
we see basically the room is totally
packed there are over 150 people outside
of uh poly Museum right now this is
waiting to get in waiting to get in so I
think also uh we have reached a
completely different level of
penetrating and and reaching out to
people uh informing about this event uh
this year so uh of course uh we had lots
of Spectators last year but but this
year the room is packed uh museum is
full uh plus a huge line in front of in
front of the museum so
um I think it's uh it's great it's great
and we take learnings also for the next
year uh to to prepare even better to to
to be able to address all those
Spectators and it also helps that you
guys have some amazing players in Poland
as well do that the defending Champion
here in Warsaw and and also rather check
the Local Hero I think he lives here in
Warsaw so that's uh that's really great
and and today both of them play with uh
Magnus so it's a it's a it's a unique
opportunity first day uh with
both polish players
playing Magnus on the first day and I
think it's uh it's great great
collection of uh of real Champs and and
of course Magnus is a great star we we
could see it also during the opening
ceremony how many questions towards him
so yeah the Stars definitely aligned
with those first couple of games Thank
you very much Adam for joining us thank
you thanks a lot and right now we are
going to go to a commercial break uh
don't forget the games are going to
continue stay tuned
[Music]
foreign